[Music]
youko fear dr. Barnes momento Muslim
enemy on a map so teen over Horine in
the mysterious Anna Allah pallets are
not idle Estonian when some hidden
events on earth could film Holly Weaver
listener
[Music]
managers at heroin must naturally
message in Medina Khalil who must now we
must not wait for a Philistine goofy
meshe me your home sir seen some Tiffany
I'm searching in Santi available as what
he had in assess he had it configure
Asli we had a deal with Matthew are
fearful of staining a little a LuAnn
Rosanna almond sterile Kofi lambda 1 e
configurable - who yesterday maja in
Kannapolis infidelity administering our
ability taken this way if the world
starting over after a pause you home at
Berea the caranfil was area in eastern
demo hotter than double burned NASA
worthless chance a Bernalillo feel her a
lottery hold the bottle in war theater
in abolished arresting an a-lister
promise not analytically I know totally
phenom the lava man said yeah he hadn't
been a la yaani
nationally and in had a minute Oh what
is she gonna be no magnetic valid yeah
yeah you can you can now configure Mary
Rogerson what it feel happy fiat of
Digimon Barbara Dinah physically
assaulted mr. ena
mechanicus of family-owned restaurant a
slab had a minute word or handle and
half of the knowledgeable
[Music]
[Music]
Lippa priests especially supporters will
officially begin the East
ozo Evonik presque risk to help you
achieve your repeal cherami leigh or
pelvis repeal - will really pitiful
kissable pets in open eyes on preview
passes the time we see new HEPA the
party visible in the cat Missal pepsi
exist the clear concept of metal
Calcutta which is perfectly second on
peps doesn't represent lobbies of pipes
are a unique collaboration between
dobkiss across a apart from pop window
mode can a person commits a demon poppy
Chicana what a Bonaparte on a party if
we pass you a goddess a lot to save
souls
socially academically before an apse
savonius only when the demo cleaners on
marinas surface phenomena these are also
from the path in Russia join pretty high
price le metió summer escalated oksana
predominant by racial diversity may have
a few mayor so I can't party but not
vomit
the liberal magic says as my campaign in
simplicity or [ __ ] spinosus will
appear magic carpets in El Centro de
Maupassant art we never pesky foster
Vltava tight hi booboo özkan özkan a
million and a party and people
proportion to destroy the possibility of
kilowatt is not a personnel
Samuel name I know Christ was impossible
to feel bridge a nearby icon populist I
am a civil this is second Avenue
especially since unknown anonymous you
whenever I ask unanimous you ready here
we go
my customers aren't interested in
iPhones or iPods they're interested in
their memories where they were able to
dance and sing to a jukebox it's all
about making people happy my name is
Perry and I'm the owner of Parrish
jukebox and pinball repair company in
Brooklyn my business is one of the few
businesses in the country that's capable
of repairing vintage jukeboxes these are
called vacuum tubes in most cases half
of them a good half of them are not good
ever since I was child I was always
interested in motors fans and things
that moved and looking at a jukebox the
arm the turntable the spinning and the
motion was something that I was very
intrigued by I do around 20 house calls
a month to repair jukeboxes
[Music]
give it correct settings tube is no good
most people I call me
they love their machines they have the
records in them from when they were
teenagers and it brings back memories
and they think that they're never gonna
work again no this one's more promising
look at this
being able to restore the machine it's
something that really makes me feel good
I always leave a house with music
playing the first time I ever made a
delivery was in the spring of 1953 and I
was 6 months old
on my father's route I grew up doing
this man my name is Walter Beckerman and
I am a seltzer man and yourselfs a man
is the order taker the bottle fixer the
driver to deliverer the salesman your
everything rolled into one if people ask
you what it is about the cells of
business that makes you want to continue
doing it
you hold that cells about and you hold
history your whole memories you hold an
object of beauty that's 1871 it still
works
without these bottles this business
doesn't exist this machine is a barnett
and foster siphon filling machine I
think it was made in London early 1900s
it's a six siphon vape filling machine
goes round through the carousel and only
one bottle goes in at a time so it's a
lot of work the reason this is a better
Seltzer is because there's nothing else
in this Seltzer other than New York City
tap water which is triple filtered
through sand charcoal and paper and co2
and fortunately as long as the machine
is fixed and I have a place to fill I
can't see any reason why this business
should be a nail in the coffin situation
where it's over it won't be over to the
last bowl of cells is squirted and I
don't see that anytime soon
[Music]
how many times you get one of the only
people in the world doing what you're
doing yeah there's other people that
have tried it but they haven't lasted my
name is I Richie and I went to Kol
winner is a carousel works and I'm Dan
Jones and I'm the other owner of
carousel works weirdo largest
manufacturer of wooden carousels in the
world art and I met through a third
party that we both knew I went over to
shop one day and we were talking and one
thing led to another and from there it
just kind of took off I was doing the
restoration he's doing carvings now
we've got a 50-50 partnership for 30
years and there's no very few partners
just last over three years so you know
it's not to say we haven't had
differences over the years and it was
like being married but not that bad we
average in different stages probably
three carousels a year we're actually
working out for right now we have
carousels all around the world we made
the Cincinnati riverfront carousel we
have one in the Bronx Zoo we have one to
Kansas City Zoo the Nashville Zoo the
Atlanta zoo the Riverbanks Zoo we even
made the Smithsonian National Zoo
carousel terror cells we'll put people
in the eye of the child oh they're
absolutely beautiful when you watch
people right occur so the kids are just
loving to go up and down and put these
big smiles and then right closer stuff
can we go again it's fantastic it is a
Leah get mascara ever faster compression
technology fatty liver Candela CL cyber
championship will travel to reach an
elephant a campaign of chivalry actually
in the field events through the veins of
you fall say you don't care that you
voltage in the pelvic Bailey and people
behaving no sir no Sally Erica variables
are alone Krishnamurthy importantly we
see amo lck barbaric Ola la primavera
Milano terrible baby Aleutian Islands
come on Kanta Dino's are away whatever
in sorrowful music first opera una volta
chiefin savanna Capelli Kristen about
importantly if actual a pal Kayla cuando
Villanova any the Laurie any recipe no
taunted whistles attended really have
that suburbia
una volta in Bobby Rahal the most
important all right more to the west is
Barbie a malicious tape you we should to
model the West a lot of material with
Roger Federer been a problem in a
wilderness area of a boy with the baby
no fatty Sally O'Malley
[Music]